Narrator: Babies cry all the time,
whether you like it or not.
And it takes a very patient
parent to make them stop.
When it comes to TV and movies, however,
a director may actually want
a baby to cry on command.
And this requires hiring someone
with a special set of skills.
That's Elaine Hall.
She's what's known in
Hollywood as a baby wrangler.
Elaine Hall: A baby
wrangler is a interpreter
between what the director
wants a young child to do
in front of a camera.
Narrator: She's worked with
infants and young children
on a variety of commercials,
TV shows, and movies,
like "The Flintstones,"
"Grace Under Fire,"
and "Akeelah tnd the Bee."
First off, where do these
crying babies come from?
Babies, just like adult actors,
come from casting calls,
but they're only legally allowed to work
for four hours a day on set,
so there's a simple trick used
to extend their camera time.
Hall: Very often, when you
see a TV show or a film,
twins are used to play one role.
Narrator: There's also a
few other rules in place
when using young actors.
Hall: For every set that has a child,
there's a studio teacher on the set.
For infants, there must be a
studio teacher and a nurse.
Narrator: For non-crying scenes,
working with babies and young children
involves making it fun for them.
Hall: Everything was made into a game.
I would put on the lens of the camera,
funny faces on the lens,
when they needed to
make direct eye contact.
I would be behind the camera
on every scene, making them laugh.
Narrator: But for crying,
it's a whole different story.
Elaine uses a special technique.
Hall: What I do to get babies to cry is,
I start to cry myself.
For example, I'll go, "Wahhhh!"
And the baby will start to cry.
When a baby, even an infant,
hears another baby cry,
the infant or the baby will
start to cry themselves.
This is an example of empathy.
It's pretty instantaneous.
Narrator: She used this technique
in "Akeelah And The Bee."
In this scene, Akeelah's
sister brings her baby
to the event, and it starts to cry.
And her technique has
never failed, so far.
Hall: My success rate is 100 percent.
Narrator: She says she's
heard of other baby wranglers
using questionable techniques
like placing bad odors
in front of the child
or making a loud noise.
But according to Elaine,
these sorts of methods
may be harmful to the child,
and should be avoided.
If the baby's face doesn't
need to be shown on camera,
oftentimes, they'll use a doll instead.
Once it's crying, how do
you get the baby to stop?
Hall: When I stop crying, and
then I'll look at the baby,
and assure the baby
that everything's safe,
I'm okay, she's okay,
then, very quickly, a
baby will stop crying.
Narrator: She may also
use rattles and bells
to help, if necessary.
Regardless of the scene,
Elaine says it's important
that the baby spend time
with the actor ahead of time.
Hall: I always have the actor and the baby
create relationship off camera,
so that it's not like
you're just plopping a kid
into a stranger's lap.